parfois les portes restent fermées
parfois elle s'ouvre avec le sourire à
quelques jours des élections municipales
opération porte-à-porte pour des membres
de la liste tous pour villepreux
l'ancienne adjointe au maire sylvie ce
vent monte elle dévoile son programme et
notamment sa position sur un projet qui
fait débat à villepreux la construction
de 250 nouveaux logements dans le
secteur du tri yann
on va arriver d'ici pas très longtemps à
13000 14000 on va mettre un pied un gros
coup de pied sur le frein sur le
développement de l'urbanisme à
villepreux
je pense que c'est vraiment plus que
raisonnable il faut absolument qu'on
trouve un équilibre urbanistique un
équilibre environnemental
il est 8 heures en équilibre financier -
de construction et plus de verts ce sont
les principales orientations de la
campagne de la candidate pour
l'environnement elle souhaite surtout
sensibiliser les plus jeunes des villes
provient on ferait de la prévention
beaucoup plus dans les écoles ce que je
pense que c'est pas trés ça se verra pas
tout de suite mais un maire doit aussi
agir pour les 10 15 ans qui viennent
ça se verra pas tout de suite mais les
enfants d'aujourd'hui dans les primaires
seront des enfants des adultes
responsables plus tard je serai
certainement plus là pour le voir mais
ça n'a aucune importance pour tenter de
convaincre les habitants de voter pour
elle sylvie ce vin monte elle organise
une dernière réunion publique le
vendredi 13 mars à l'école gérard
philipe